est ce que vous vous intéressez au
football ah non non mais ça tombe bien
voici luis fernandez
à tanger
c'est fallait sait pas quand même parce
que c'est beaucoup plus sympa comparé
pl1 toujours plein abbas est plein mais
je le dise - lundi en deux temps bien ça
va parfait tout le monde parle de la
vouge pour ça que vous êtes là je vous
remercie d'être là pour vous exprimer
pas très souvent depuis quelques temps
je vous remercie d'avoir choisi tout le
monde en parle
alors le 3 décembre 2000 après une
défaite à 1,5 contre sedan le président
du psg laurent perpère limoges
l'entraîneur philippe bergeron qui avait
remplacé alain giresse qu'elle était lui
aussi viré et fait appel à vous et
c'était la fin de votre rate un poste
très délicat le raid est du cas c'est la
fin de notre année sabbatique et on
parlait de vous pour l'om et vous êtes
venu donc au psg alors dès que vous
arrivez au psg om et autres et autres
dès que vous arrivez au psg vous
multipliez les déclarations d'amour pour
les joueurs pour les dirigeants pour le
public vous redonner espoir à tout le
monde
malheureusement les résultats n'ont pas
suivi et on dit aujourd'hui l'effet
fernandes n'a pas joué la plaque lui
qu'elle peut jouer ou bien alors trois
pelles et du repas 10 ans et louise non
mais les schémas défensifs c'est qu'il
n'apprécie pas plus que ça ça va se
ressentir dans l'interview
pas du tout vent ça c'est pas vrai j'ai
vraiment et dans les couloirs et appelle
le baltringue voir comment ça se traduit
à l'antenne moi j'étais bien peu d'un
tempérament maintenant qu'ils passent du
bon côté mais il sait qu'il peut prendre
un coup de boule en même temps il va
essayer de gérer tout ça non mais bon
c'est la réalité que je raconte la trois
victoires en 15 matches dont une contre
uc contre thouars sait même pas que ça
existait là vous allez gagner un 3e
division qui est 32e de la coupe 2 en
troisième division du national est
d'accord mais sans jouer sur la route
bien alors donc voilà alors dans la
ligue des champions ont gagné le match
aller contre milan ac 1-1 et samedi
dernier il ya eu marseille 0-1 0-1 et
mardi le retour de milan ac 1-1
c'est ça un vrai pont on va voir dans
cette formidable moi je trouve là dans
le match mardi